hello everyone and welcome to this
really interesting video on football
data analysis project using python this
is going to be a live tutorial
now in this video
we'll be performing a hands-on
demonstration
on analyzing and visualizing the english
premier league data set for the
2020-2021 season which is the last
season of epl
let me show you the data set first that
we'll be
using for our demo session
all right so here is the epl 2020 2021
season data set that we'll be using for
our demo
so the first column you can see the
names of the different players that play
in the english premier league so we have
around
532 players participating in the epl
last season
then the second column is about the club
they belong to you can see we have the
different clubs first is chelsea we have
manchester city
man united liverpool leicester west ham
united tottenham arsenal
and if i scroll down you can see the
other clubs such as the
clubs like aston villa we have everton
volvo phantom wanderers we have crystal
palace and others
now coming to the
third column which is about
the nationality of the players that is
the players
belonging to the different nations we
have england i think this is senegal
germany
we have france spain italy brazil
croatia and others
now
the fourth column is about position that
is the
position at which
these players play at now you can see
some of the players play
at different
position they can play for two different
positions like for example mission mount
from chelsea plays as a midfielder as
well as forward
now
edward mendy is a goalkeeper df is for
defender
so on and so forth
now
next we have the age of the players we
have the total number of matches played
by
each player in the last season of
epl
then we have the
total number of starts the player got
that is whether the player was part of
the playing 11 or not then we have the
total number of minutes the player had
played
the last season of epl this is the total
number of minutes the player had played
next we have the total number of goals
scored by each player we have the total
number of ss given by each player
then we have
passes attempted
the percentage of pass is completed
up next we have
total number of goals scored from
penalties and then we have
total number of penalties that were
taken
now we have two different columns xg and
xa
so xg is the expected number of goals
from the player in a match and x a is
the expected number of asses from the
player in a match and finally we have
the last two columns
total number of yellow cards received by
the player in the
last season of epl and then we have the
total number of red cards
received by the player in the last
season of epl that is 2020 2021. so we
are going to use this data set and we'll
be analyzing
and answering specific questions such as
the total number of goals scored the
total goals scored on penalties and the
total goals that were missed
while taking penalties
then we have
players from different nations playing
in epl then we'll also look at which
clubs have the maximum number of players
in the squad we'll be also analyzing the
players based on their age group then
we'll see the total
goals scored by the top 10 players in
the last season of epl and
will be visualizing these results with
the help of different charts like the
bar chart the pie chart
and we'll also create
plots
using libraries like cbon and matplotlib
so let's head over to our jupiter
notebook let me show you the jupyter
notebook that we'll be using
cool so this is my
jupiter notebook that i'll be using for
this live session today
you can see i have renamed the notebook
as epl 2020 2021 data analysis demo
and i have
some of the cells filled already this is
to make sure we save some time
cool
so first and foremost let's go ahead and
import the necessary libraries that
we'll be requiring for our demo
so first i'll import
the data manipulation library which is
pandas as pd
and then we'll import
numpy
as np
then i'll have
matplotlib
dot
pi plot
as plt
after that
we'll be importing the second data
visualization library which is c bond as
sns
finally i'll say
percentage
matplotlib inline
so we'll get our results just
right below the code once we
create the charts and graphs
so let me hit shift enter to run this
first cell
all right
you can see we have successfully
imported the
different libraries now the next step is
to load our epl data set so i'll create
a variable called epl underscore df
which essentially stands for data frame
i'll say pd dot
since it's a csv file that we just saw
i'll say read underscore csv
now within the
quotations we are going to pass in the
location of the file followed by the
file name and the extension of the file
okay so i have copied the file location
let me just paste it here
within the quotes
now we are going to give
one more
backslash so that it reads the
location correctly
i guess you don't have to do this if you
are on
a linux or mac system
now after this
we are going to give two more
backslash and we are going to give the
file name which is epl underscore 20
underscore 21 dot
csv
cool
now
next line i am going to print the
head of the data frame that is the first
five rows of the data frame that is epl
underscore df
so i will say epl underscore df dot head
let's run it now you can see the output
we have the first five rows printed from
the data set
and you can see the different columns
that we have
all right
now in the next step
let's check
the
info function that will give the total
number of columns that are there
as well as display the total
non-null values in each of the columns
so i'll say
epl
underscore
df dot
info
let's run it you can see we have the
different column names and on the top
you can see there are total
532 entries
we have total 18 columns you can see
total of 18 columns these are the total
columns the column names and on the
right you can see the total number of
normal objects which means we do not
have any null
value in any of the cells or any of the
columns and at the bottom you can see
the memory usage and the data types
all right
now let's go ahead and use the describe
function to get some summary statistics
about our data set
so i'll say
epl underscore df dot describe
let's run it
and now you can see we have
the count mean standard deviation the
minimum value the maximum value 25th
percentile the 50th percentile and the
75th percentile
now this describe function only works on
numeric columns
cool
now let me show you a way in which you
can check the total number of null
values that are there in each of the
columns for that we are going to use
the is any function and over that i am
going to use the sum function to get the
total number of null values
here i will say
epl underscore df
dot
and say is any dot
sum
now let me run it
here you can see
we do not have any null values for any
of the columns
cool
now let me show you the process in which
you can create two more columns
such as the minutes per match and we'll
create another column that is the goals
per match
so for that
i'm going to first
call my data frame which is epl
underscore df and within square brackets
i'm going to give my
new column name that is
minutes
per
match there should be a valid
python name
i'll say equal to
now the minutes per match should be
equal to the total number of minutes
divided by the matches that is the
number of matches played so i'll say
epl underscore df
i'll divide
minutes
by
let me give a
bracket here i'll say
epl underscore
df
and then
i'll divide it by the
matches column
and we're going to set the type as
integer
all right
then the second column i'll create is
goals per match so i'll say epl
underscore df
and my new column name is goals
per
match
equal to
let's start with the bracket we'll say
epl underscore df
we consider the
goals column
and then
we'll divide it by
epl
underscore df
give a square bracket and say
matches
and we are going to convert the
type as
float
cool
let's run it
now if i say
print
pl
let's code df you can see
or let's say epl underscore df dot head
to print the first five rows
here you can see we have created
two more
columns let me just remove this print
statement and we'll run it again
now you can see we have created two more
columns that is the minutes per match
for each of the different players and
then we have the goals per match for
each of the different players
all right
now
in the next cell we are going to
calculate the
overall total goals that were scored in
the 2021
or 2020 2021 epl season
so let's see
total goals i'll create a variable
called total underscore
goals equal to
i'll say epl underscore df
we're going to take the
goals column
and then
i'm going to use the
sum function
now let's print
the
total
goals
if you hit tab it will auto complete
let me run it
okay
to remove
goals now you can see
there were total
986 schools that were scored in the last
season of english premier league
now let's find out out of this 986 goals
how many goals were scored in penalties
so for that
we are going to use the penalty
underscore goals column
and create a variable called total
underscore
penalty
equal to
we'll say epl underscore
df
then we are going to consider the
penalty underscore goals column
then i'll say dot
sum to find the total number of
goals that were scored in
penalties
if you hit tab
it will give you a prompt let me select
the second one
run it
there you go
here you can see
out of 986 total goals that were scored
in the epl last season
102 goals were scored out of penalties
now in the next analysis we are going to
see the total number of
penalty attempts that were taken and how
many
converted
so for that let's create another
variable called total
underscore
penalty
items
equal to
now this should be
the penalty attempted
column so i'll say epl underscore df
we are going to consider the
penalty
underscore
attempted column
say dot sum to find the total number of
penalties that were taken
and we're going to use the print
statement
let me hit tab and i'll select penalty
items
let's run it
so
overall 125 penalties were taken out of
which 102 got converted the rest all
permissed
we are going to create our first
plot
in our live analysis about
the epl 2020-2021 season so we are going
to create a pie chart for penalties
scored and missed
okay
so first of all we are going to set our
plot
figure
to a certain
size let's say
and say figure
size
equal to
and this will be a
tuple
let's say i'll say
13 comma 6
now
i'll say
penalty
not
scored
equal to
a data frame that is epl underscore
df
i'm going to pass in my
multi underscore
attempted column
and summit
and i am going to subtract the
total
penalty goals
that is total underscore penalty
goals
see data equal to
this will be a list so i'll say
penalty
not score let me just copy and paste it
comma
we are going to pass in
total
penalty goals
also give
labels to our pie chart
so the labels
will be
penalties
missed
penalties scored
make sure you put it within
quotations
we are going to give
color to the
pie chart so for that i'm going to use
my
cbon library i'll see sns dot
color underscore
palette
say i'll set my color palette to
set 2.
you can check for different
color palettes just google
seaborn
color palette and click on the first
link
if you scroll here you can see the
different
color palettes
you can see tab 10
then you also have
hls
which usl which is for hustle
you have set two paired
but scroll down you have rocket
underscore r rocket you also have cube
helix
then magma
and others
all right let me come back
so i'm using the set to palette
and we'll see plt dot
create the pie chart we are going to use
the
pi function
and we'll pass in our data
followed by the
labels parameter which is equal to
the labels that we have declared above
which is this one
okay
now
i'll say the colors parameter should be
equal to
the color palette that we have defined
in the above line
next
we are going to use auto
pct
so this auto pct enables you to display
the
percentage value using python string
formatting
so you can use the auto pct to display
your
percentage values let me give a certain
formatting
percent
dot
o
f which is for string
will give
two percentage values
finally i'm going to say plt dot show to
display my
chart
cool
now let's run this
okay there is an error here which is
plot dot figure
this should be plot dot figure and not
underscore
there you go
you can see we have our first
visualization for the 2021
epl data analysis demo
you can see 82 percent of penalties were
scored while 18 percent were
missed
next we're going to find the total
number of
unique positions for which
each of the players play for that is
this will also tell us the total number
of positions that are there
in football
so i'll say epl underscore df
let's consider the position
column
and i'm going to use the unique function
to find the total number of unique
positions that are there such as the
center forward midfielder
defenders goalkeepers etc
if i run it you see here
we have
goalkeeper
midfielder and forward forward defender
midfielder
defender and midfielder etc
now you can see some of the
positions are
a combination of two positions which
means a few of the players
play for two different positions
on the pitch
all right
moving forward
we are going to see the
total number of
forward players that played in the last
season of epl so for that i'm going to
see
epl underscore df
again within square brackets i'll see
epl underscore df and we are going to
consider the
position column
basically subsetting the data frame to
derive valuable information
now this should be equal to equal to my
value which is
f w that is forward
let's run it there you go
so here if i scroll down you can see the
different players that played for
there are total 81 rows
which means
81 players
in the epl played as
forwards you can see timo warner from
chelsea tammy abraham who currently
please for
aroma in italy we have oliver zero
then we have rhyme sterling
also have billy sharp from sheffield
united and
daniel also
next
question that we are going to answer is
we'll see the players from different
nations so we'll see in epl
what are the nations or the total number
of nations from which players come from
so i'm going to use this function called
numpy.size
and within
brackets i'll see epl underscore df
we're going to consider the nationality
column to find the count
so i'll say nationality
and we are going to use the
unique function to get the total number
of unique nations from which
the players play in the epl
but run it you can see here there are
total 59 nations from which the
different players
play from
now let's see
the most players come from which nations
for
that
i'm going to create a variable called
nationality equal to i'm going to use my
data frame epl underscore df
followed by
the
group by function
first we are going to group by
nationality column
and then i'll say dot
size
and we are going to sort
values in ascending order
so for that i'm going to use the
ascending parameter and i'll
set it to false which means we are going
to print in descending order and not
ascending
next
i'll say
nationality.head since i want to know
the
top 10 nations
from which most of the players
come from
we're also going to plot it
there should be a bar chart so i'll say
kind
equal to bar
let's give a
figure size
equal to
let's say 12 comma 6
and now
i'm going to say color equal to
we're again going to use the
seaborn color palette so i'll say sns
dot color underscore
palette
this time we are going to choose let's
see magma
all right
i think everything is fine let's just
run it
great
now if i scroll down
you can see the different
nationalities the top 10 nations from
which the most players come from of
course since
epl
is in england or is it
hosted in england so most of the players
are from england
then we have
the most number of players playing from
france brazil
spain
this is ireland i guess then we have
portugal scotland netherland wales and
belgium
cool
now
moving forward
let's come to the
next cell we are going to see the clubs
with maximum players in their squad
this will tell us the
clubs
let's say the top five clubs which have
the maximum players in their squad or
had the maximum number of players in the
2020-2021 season
we're going to consider the club column
and we are going to count
the total number of players
so i'll say values
rather value underscore counts
let's use the n largest function to get
the
top five clubs and we are going to plot
it again
this will be a bar chart again so i'll
say kind equal to bar
comma and we'll say
color
equal to sns dot
color underscore
palette
let's choose a new palette
namely
viridis so i write it correctly
b-i-r-i-d-i-s fine
let's run it
and here you can see we have
west bromwich albion
which had nearly 30 players in the squad
then
manchester united i think they had 29
players in their squad last season then
arsenal with the third highest number of
players
followed by southampton and everton so
last three had the same number of
players close to
29 or 28
all right
now similarly if you want to check the
clubs with the least players in their
squad
we just need to use the
and
smallest function
here i can copy this cell of code
we'll just edit it
instead of enlargest
i'll say and
smallest
rest everything remains the same
you can see here
leeds united had the least number of
players in the squad followed by
manchester city crystal palace tottenham
hotspur and west ham united
cool now in the next analysis we are
going to see the
players based on
age groups so we are going to define
four age groups let's say players
less than 20 years of age than players
between 20 to 25 years of age
then we have players from
25
and 30 that is 25 between 25 and 30 and
finally we have
the different players who are above 30
years of age
for that i'll create
my first variable which is under 20
this should be equal to
l
underscore df
i'll say epl underscore df
we'll consider the age column
again we are subsetting the data frame
so i'll say less than equal to 20.
then we'll have
age between 20 underscore 25
equal to
epl
underscore
tf
subset as epl underscore df
consider the each column
it should be
greater than
20
i'll say
ambushant
and epl underscore df
because the h column should be
less than equal to 25
let's copy this
next we are going to see
for age between 25 and 30 so i'll edit
my variable name
25 underscore 30
here
this should be greater than 25 and less
than equal to 30.
cool
finally we'll have
players
above 30
equal to i'll say epl underscore df
within square brackets i'll say epl
underscore
df we'll consider the h column
should be greater than
30.
cool let me run it
and now in the next cell which is
already filled
this is to create the pie chart for
the above age groups that we created to
see the players based on
different age groups
so this is
very similar to creating a pie chart
again so first of all i am creating a
numpy array for all these
four variables
and we are going to consider only the
name
then i am setting my labels as
less than or equal to 20 greater than
equal to 20 and less than equal to 25
greater than equal to 25 and less than
equal to 30 and
then above 30
i have the title as total players with
age
groups let's see
the font size as 20
cool let's run it
and you can see we have our pie chart
so from the pie chart you can see
the last season of english premier
league
at least 37 of the players for aged
between 25 and 30
and then we have
35 percent of players who were between
20 and 25
13.3 percent of players were above 30
years of age and we had
14.7 percent players less than equal to
20 years of age
now
if you were to check the total
under 20 players in each club
so for that
i'll say
players
under
20
equal to
again we are going to subset our
original data frame
it will underscore df i'll say epl
underscore
df
age should be less than
20
next
we'll say
years underscore under
20
consider the club column
then
values
underscore
count
let's plot
i'll say
kind equal to bar
and we are going to choose the color
equal to sns dot
color
palette
let's see
we'll go with cube helix
cool
okay let's debug the error there are
some errors it says series object no
attribute values underscore count
this should be value underscore counts
now let me run it
cool you can see
there are
seven players or there were total seven
players in the manchester united club
who were less than 20 years of age
followed by
five players in wolverhampton wanderers
then shipped united
and the rest of the other clubs you can
see
now let's find out
all the players who were aged less than
20
in manchester united
well let me just scroll down cool
so here i'll see
clears
under
20
again we're going to say players
under 20.
to
subset based on club equal to equal to
i'll give the value as
manchester
united
run it
and you can see the
seven players that we saw above here you
could see we had seven players in
manchester united that were aged below
20
and the names are
mission greenwood we have brandon
williams
ahmad
diallo
anthony alanga
we also have william thomas fish
cool
and you can see that ages here 18 19 all
of them are less than 20 years of age
and similarly you can also
check for other club let's see you want
to see the under 20 players in chelsea
just need to replace or subset our
club for chelsea
there are only two players who were aged
less than 20
callum hatson odoi and billy gilmore
cool
we're going to create a plot to see the
average age of players in each club
for that i'll say plt.
take the
figure size
as let's say
12 comma 6
then we're going to use the c bond
library
and the
box plot this time
so the box plot is a
good way of finding the variability in
your data it will give us the mean the
median
the 25th percentile the 50th percentile
the 75th percentile the maximum value
and the minimum value
and the box plot will also show if there
are any outliers in the
data
so my x will be club
my y value would be age
and my data will be my original data
frame that is
epl underscore df
lc
plt dot x
ticks
and we are going to see
rotation equal to 90 degrees
let's run it
if i scroll down here you can see we
have the box plot
so
for chelsea you can see the
minimum age value the maximum age value
and then you also have
an outlier here i'm assuming this is
someone who's aged above 36 or 37
and then
here you can see the
median
and similarly you can see for the rest
of the other clubs now if you notice
i can see here
that
crystal palace
has
the highest average each if you see this
line
now this line is the maximum
crystal palace
verify
the clubs with the average
age of players
i'll say
let's say num underscore player
equal to
epl let me just scroll down
score
df dot
we'll use the group by function
on
club
and i'll say
size
to that i'll say data equal to
epl underscore df
or
then i'll group it by
club
see age
dot
sum
and we are going to divide it by
the
variable that we created above that is
num underscore clear
finally i'll say data dot
sort
underscore
values
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error it says sort
underscore values got an unexpected
keyword argument ascending okay there's
a spelling mistake this should be
ascending
there you go
so as we saw above in the box plot now
here you can see
crystal palace has the highest average
age
in that team which is
28.3 years then we have west ham united
followed by burnley now if i scroll down
manchester united
had the
least average age of players that means
they had a very young team that played
in the 2020-2021 season after that there
were
west ham aston villa and other clubs
great
now in this cell we are going to find
the total ss from each club
for that i am going to group by club and
we are going to find the sum
over the ss column
after that i am going to create a bar
plot
the x axis we'll have the club names on
the y axis we have the total number of
ss
then i'm setting the palette the color
palette to set to
we have an x label we have a y label
we have the font size for the labels
i'm going to rotate the
x-axis labels by 75 degrees
we have the figure size set and the
title as plot of clubs versus the
total
this should be assist
let me run it
and you can see here
we have the
total number of ss
for each of the
clubs as you can see manchester city had
the highest number of assets which were
above
50
or around 55
cool
let's see
the
players
who gave the most
asses in the last season of epl
so for that i'll create a variable
called top
10
ss
equal to
i'll use my data frame name epl
underscore df
followed by
name
then
club
then
this column
and i also want the
matches column
and i'm going to use the n largest
function to find the
top 10 players
so i'll say n equal to 10
columns
equal to
ss
let's print the top 10
ss
let's run it
okay again there is an error let's debug
it
sees invalid syntax
let me check
club
assist
matches then we have enlarged equal to
n equal to 10
columns equal to ss
and
this should be a comma
cool
and here you can see we have
harry kane
from
the last season of epl who gave
the maximum message that is 14 followed
by kevin
de bruyne
from manchester city who gave 12 vs
followed by bruno fernandes from
manchester united he's a portugal player
and he gave 12 vs
song hyung min from tottenham hospital
he plays for
south korea and he also gave
tennis jack grillewski tennis's then we
have marcus rashford jimmy vardy timo
werner and other players
all right
now in the
current cell which is already filled we
are going to find the
total goals from each club
earlier we saw the total assets from
each club now this will show us the
total goals from each club
if i run it
now you can check
we have
manchester city which scored above 80
goals
last season followed by
united that is close to 70 or exactly 70
goals they had scored followed by
tottenham hotspur we have liverpool
leicester
by shayfield united and fulham as well
as burnley had
close to 30 or less than 30 goals
in fact seafield united scored less than
20 goals
cool
next we are going to check the most
goals by players
so i'll say
top underscore 10 underscore
goals
equal to
i'll say epl underscore df
again
we are going to
take the name column
followed by
the
club
by
this time we are going to consider the
goals column
also take the matches column
say and
largest
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
say n equal to 10
columns
equal to
goals
and let's print
pairs with the most number of goals
you can see here
kane played
35 matches in the last season of epl and
scored the maximum number of goals so he
should have won the
golden boot as well so he had scored 23
goals and if you see the above
table that we created he also gave the
most number of ss
so he's a brilliant player from england
plays as a striker and currently the
captain of england as well
after that we had mohamed salah who
scored
22 goals followed by bruno fernandez who
scored 18 goals
from 37 matches
then we have song hyung min we have
patrick
bamford from
leeds united who scored 17 goals
etc
in the next cell
we are going to find out the top 10
goals per match
that is the
goals scored
in each of the matched we are going to
find the percentage
i'll create a variable called top 10
goals per match
go to epl underscore df
i'll click the
name
and
also take the
goals per match column
if you remember we had created this
goals per match column above let me just
show you in case you
forgot here you can see we had created
this extra column called goals per match
this is the last column that we have in
our data frame
is basically the total number of goals
divided by the total number of matches
the player had played
i scroll down
we are going to take the name column the
goals per match
next
we will consider the
just column
and then we'll also take the
goals column
dot i'll use the n
largest function and say
n equal to 10
comma
columns
equal to
per
match
finally let's print the top 10
goods
per match
here you can see
we have
akane scored
0.6 goals in a match then we have
mohammed salah with 0.59
joe willock
with 0.5
jesse lingard scored
9 goals in 16 matches so his goals per
match
stands at
0.5 basically it is the total number of
goals divided by the total number of
matches
cool
in the next cell
we are going to create a pie chart that
will show us the goals with
ss and without ss
so i'll start with my pie chart as
plt
dot
figure
will set the
figure size
ooh 14 comma 7
create a variable called ss
equal to
we are going to find the total number of
ss
so
i'll subset my
ss column and i'm going to use the sum
function over it
then i'll see data equal to
are going to take
the total goals
minus
ss
comma and then we'll have access
let's
set the labels as well and see labels
equal to
goals
without
ss
and next
label will be
goals with
ss
next we'll say color equal to
sns dot
color palette
say i'll take set one
and finally
we're going to use the plt dot
pi function
keep my data
and
labels equal to
labels
colors equal to the color that we just
set above
again use the auto pct parameter to give
the percentage values
i'll say within quotations
percentage
dot
0 f percentage percentage
display i'll say plt dot show
everything is fine let me just recheck
it and we'll run it
it says pi got an unexpected error color
this should be colors equal to color
list not defined again let's okay this
should be plt dot show
there you go
so you see we have our pie chart and in
the pie chart you can see at least 69
percent of the goals were scored with
asses and the rest of the 31 percent
goals in the last season of english
premier league were scored without ss
coming to the final
plot in our
live demo session on
english premier league data analysis we
are going to see the top 10 players with
the most yellow cards
so basically the players who commit the
most number of fouls in a game
are given a yellow card or a red card
so for here
i'm using the yellow cards column and i
am
going to find out the
first 10 players with the most number of
yellow cards received in the last season
of utl
let's run it
and if you see
we have
john
mcginn who plays for i guess aston villa
received the
most number of yellow cards that is 12
followed by the captain of
manchester united this is very
surprising
harry maguire got
11 yellow cards last season followed by
conor
gallagher
and we have douglas lewis kevin phillips
mason holgate as well in this as well as
ruben nevis
okay
so that brings us to our live demo
session on
football data analysis using the english
premier league 2020 2021 data set you
understood how to load the data set then
we explored
different functions
that are available in numpy and pandas
after that you saw how to create pie
charts bar graphs
and then you also created a box plot
we saw the
total number of goals scored by each
club the total number of ss the players
with the highest number of goals the
players with the highest number of asses
then the goals that were scored in
penalties and without penalties
all right
live video session on
epl 2020 2021 data analysis project by
simply loan i hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video
hello everyone and welcome to this
interesting video on ipl data analysis
by simply alone
indian premier league that is ipl is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
ipl 2022 will begin on 26th of march so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held ipl auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using python and
jupyter notebook to answer special
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so i'm on my jupyter notebook
and this is the file that we are going
to use
so here you can see i have
some of the cells already filled in
so this will save us some time and we
can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that i'll be using or the
ipython notebook
cool
so first let's go ahead and import all
the crucial libraries that will be
needed for our analysis so here you can
see i am importing the pandas library
the numpy library these are for data
manipulation and numerical computation
then we have cbon and matplotlib for
data visualization
then
i have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code
cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we will import
all the libraries okay it's done
now the next step is i'm going to create
a data frame in the name of ipl
and here i'm importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandas library so
pd here has been imported as pandas i am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is ipl
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
csv is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have
successfully imported or loaded our data
set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so i'll use the head function
for this
ipl dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the
player was sold or whether the player
was a draft pick so here rashid khan
from afghanistan hardik pandya then we
have
subman gill these are all
draft pick and then we have the
price at which
the players were listed in the ipl
auction then we have the
type of player whether the player is a
bowler an all-rounder a batsman
or
a wicketkeeper
then we have the cost in rupees this is
in crores so basically this column tells
us the
price at which the player was sold in
the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars
after that we have
2021 squad basically
this means
in last year's ipl where was the player
so here you can see rasat khan was
playing
for srh the sunrises hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for gujarat titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for mumbai indians
for past few seasons including 2021 but
this season is going to play for gujarat
titans
so on and so forth
now
let's see the total number of players
that are present in the data set and the
total columns that are there for this
i'm going to use
the shape attribute so i'll write
ipl.shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were
draft pick also
and there are total
eight columns in my data frame ipl
next let's use the info function to
check the columns the data types and the
total
non-null objects so i'll say
ipl dot info which is a function so i
have to use
brackets there you go so here you can
see it saves total 633 entries from 0 to
632
data columns we have total 8 columns and
then these are the
different
column names and here you can see the
total
normal objects
present in the
column
and here you can see the data types
and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the
data set so if i say ipl dot columns and
run it it will give me
all the different column names that are
present in the data frame
now as i said
the first column which is unnamed
colon 0 is
actually unnecessary so we are going to
drop it for that
we are going to use the
dot drop function
and then i have passed in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there
and then i say in place equal to true
which means it will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the
unnamed column which was the first
column in the data frame and now we have
successfully removed it so player
becomes the first column in the data
frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so i'll say
ipl dot i'm going to use the is null
function
followed by this sum function if i run
this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values similarly base price and type
column also don't have any null values
but you can see cost and rupees and
cost in dollars have
nearly 396
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
ipl auction and hence there was no price
associated and then you can see there
were a few
players who were not part of the ipl
squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the rows that have
cost in dollar as null or nan so here i
have
used ipl and after that i am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then i've used these null function
if i run this
you can
notice the
cost in
dollars column all these values are nan
or
null
and even the same
rows have
nan for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the
next task is to
fill these null values or nan values
with
zeros so for that i'm going to use the
fill any function and here i have passed
in zero so all the null values in the
data set will be replaced with zero
for cost in
rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it
all right
ok
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means
we will check the rows that have null
values for the 2021 squad column
so what i'll do is i'll say
ipl
within
square brackets i'll say ipl and then
i'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 squad
and then after this i'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if i run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is we will
replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 square column with
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with
zero here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
i'll say ipl
i'll pass in my column name which is
2021 squad
equal to
i'll say
ipl
2021
squad
dot
fill
any
which is the function and here i'll pass
in a
text or a string saying not
participated
all right
let's run it
before that let me just scroll it down
now i'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
i'll just say ipl
dot
is null
and then i am going to use this sum
function
if i run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence
now you can see none of the
columns in the ipl data frame have null
value so it shows zero
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called
status
which will hold two values
sold and unsold
but before that we are going to
slice
our data frame so here i am looking for
all the rows where
cost in rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
i am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the
cost in rupees is greater than zero
now
i'm going to create
another
column called status so i have written
ipl
within square brackets i'm passing in
the column name which is status and
that will be equal to the team
replaced by
soul value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if i just say ipl
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so
it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names i am using the
duplicated function and i'll say keep
equal to false which means i don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalitha we have
two entries so lalithyadev here is an
all-rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 ipl
and
last year
he was playing for the delhi capitals
and this year also
he is
sold
to delhi capitals
next we have
lalitha
who happens to be a bowler so this is
again different lalitha
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have amit mishra
who earlier used to play with the delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
so on and so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shringa as well and
shivam mishra
all right
now
let's answer a very basic question
we are going to
find out how many players
have participated
in the 2022 ipl auction
for that we have already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again i am going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets i am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from kegel
up next we are going to find
how many types of players have
participated
so i am going to say types equal to
say ipl
i'll use the column name which is type
and i'm going to find the
count of
each type of players that are present in
the data frame
i'm going to use the values underscore
counts function
then i'll say
type
dot
reset underscore index
if i run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types and not type
so let's run it
you can see here
we have the different
types of players so all rounders there
are total 242 all rounders are part of
the auction then we have 215 bowlers 112
batsmen's and 64 wicket keepers
now using the above table that we just
created
i'm going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that i'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt.pi
i am using
types.values since i want
only the values from this table
and then
i'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
i've used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space
and then this is my format in which i
want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution i am going to use shadow so
it says
shadow equal to true which is another
parameter
or an argument and then i am going to
start my angle at 60 degrees
and here i have used a title called role
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally i'm saying plt dot plot
so let me just run it
there you go so here we have a nice pie
chart or a pie plot so you can see the
different pies here
we have all-rounder wicket keeper
batter and bowler
so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by bowlers then we have 17.69
percent batters and 10.11 percent wicket
keepers which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another
bar plot or a bar graph that will tell
us how many players were sold and unsold
so for this i am going to use a count
plot so we will create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors
one will have orange the other one will
have pink and i'm using labels so to
label the x-axis and y-axis i have sold
or unsold by label will have number of
players the title of my bar graph would
be sold versus unsold i've given a font
size of 15 and i'm saying
plt.plot
now the function that you see here at
the bottom
will display the data labels for each of
the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so i have used a figure size of 10 comma
5
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
i'll say
ipl dot we can use the group by function
and i want to group it by
status column
and
the value that i want to measure is
the
players count
so i'll say players
rather player
and then i'm going to use the
count function if i run this you can see
here
i've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players are unsold are
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition i'm passing is
in the teams column the value shouldn't
be unsold
so
players bought means the value should be
sold so here i am using this condition
and the rest of the things remains the
same
one improvement i have done here is i'm
using x6
rotation equal to 70 degrees this
basically means the x labels would be
tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot
there you go so here you can see i have
the title players bought by each team on
the y-axis we have the number of players
and on the x-axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see it better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just
show you so
gujarat titans have totally purchased 22
players
then
delhi capitals have total 24 players in
their squad
again lucknow supergiants have 22
players
if i scroll and see again
bangalore loyal challengers or rcb the
royal challenges bangalore have
22 players in the team
and rajasthan royals and sunrises
hyderabad have
24 and 23 players respectively in their
teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns called
retention
base price
and base price unit
for that
first of all i am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to
ipl base price let me just run it
and then
i'm going to replace
these values that are present in the
list 2 crore 40 lakh 20 lakh 1 crore 30
lakh 1.5 crore
with
from auction
and i'm saying in place equal to true
let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column i'm going to replace draft pick
value as 0 so let's run that as well
and now
i'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
breeze spice unit and base price so
basically i'm splitting
on this piece
that i have let me show you how it is
going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what i did was i
replaced the draft pick values to 0
and then the rest of the values will be
split into two columns called base price
unit so basically it will have the unit
of the base price let's say crores or
lakhs
and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40
20 20 so on and so forth let me just
scroll down
and
run that particular cell
now to create
these two columns the base price unit
column and the base underscore price
column i have used the lambda function
and i'm splitting based on the space
let's just run it
now i have replaced
retained with 0
and let me show you the
final data frame that i have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to 0
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that i wanted to
create
so one is called retention
so zeros refer to draft pick
any other value will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores
lacks
and the value base prices 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so i'll say
ipl let me just scroll down
dot
i'm going to use the
group by function
then i'll say
team
comma
retention
and i am going to
use the value
as
retention because i want to find the
count of
retained players
then i'll say colon
-1
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because i have
grouped by team and then retention so i
have chinese super kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players
coming to delhi capitals delhi capitals
in the 2022
ipl auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
i scroll down let me talk about let's
say punjab kings they have
pegged 23 players from the auction and
retained two players from
the team last year
talking about
rcb or all challenges bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained
three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here i am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold
and i'm going to use another parameter
called hue for the different colors so
here i have used hue
as type because i want to
show the players in each team based on
the different types
again i have given my
title to the bar plot
and then i have the x label the wire
label and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if i scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for blue
orange or yellow
it's for all rounder green is for batter
and
red
which also looks like maroon is for
wicket keepers
and on the
x axis you can see the different team
names
all
right now let's answer another
couple of questions so here i have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team
so to solve this question i'll
say my data frame name that is ipl
then i'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because you
want to see the highest amount spent and
not
from the retained players
then i'm going to
group
by
i'll say
team
and then
i'll say
cost in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees
that is in crores
and
i'll say
max
colon
minus 1
dot
sort underscore
values
i'll say ascending
equal to false which means i want the
sorted
result in descending
order okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it
sees there's a spelling mistake this
should be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
mumbai indians
have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be shan kissin
then
chennai super kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores kolkata knight riders
bought
shreya's air for 12.25 crores
and so on and so forth
so these are the highest amounts spent
on a single player by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at
maximum value or maximum price
now if you follow ipl
the maximum
price
at which a player was retained happens
to be ravindra jadeja so let's see at
what price was he retained
i'll say
retention
equal to equal to
i'll say
retained
then i'll say
sort underscore
values
by equal to
i'll use the
same column
cost in
rupees that's in cross
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot
head
and i want to find the top player
again there's some error
let's see
where is the error
she's ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket i should say
bye
i think this should be
fine now let's run it
there you go
so you can see here our result is player
name ravindra jadeja who was retained
for
16 crores by chennai super kings
cool
now
the next cell of code will
display or print the top five bowlers
who have been picked
in this year's ipl based on
their cost in inr
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shradler who was
bought by delhi capitals earlier he was
part of csk
for 10.75 crores then we have prasith
krishna who has been bought by rajasthan
royals this time
last year he was with kkr and he has
been bought for 10 crore similarly
lockheed ferguson has been bought by
gujarat titans
and he played for kkr last season he has
been bought for 10 crores while his base
price was too crows then we have avish
khan
you can see avishkhan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by lucknow super giants again
and last year he was part of the delhi
capitals
now you can replace
this value suppose let's say you want to
find the top five batsman's picked or
batters picked with the highest amount
you can just see
batter instead of bowler and if i run
this
you can see here surya sayer was bought
by
kolkata night riders for 12.25 crores
last year he was part of delhi capitals
then you have
shrimran hitmaiere who's from
west indies he has been
picked by the rajasthan royals for eight
point five crores then we have rahul
tribati
shikha dhaban and devda particle
now if you wanted to check for let's see
all round those
you can replace batter with all rounder
if i run this
you can see
lamb living stone has been bought by
punjab kings this season for
11.5 crores this beast price was just
one crore and last year he was part of
the rajasthan royals
then we have a player from sri lanka
asuranga then we have hershel patel
shahrukh khan and rahul devatia who have
been
the top five all-rounders picked at
highest amount
cool
finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the ipl
last season but were not picked for this
year's ipl
so for that what i'm doing is first i'm
renaming my
2021 squad column
this column i want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
i am going to find out the unsold
players so here i am saying previous
team not equal to
not participated
and then
i'm using another condition the team
should be equal to equal to unsold and
i'm going to find out only the player
and the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the ipl last
season but
they haven't been picked this season and
last season they had played for let's
say suresh shrine update for csk steve
smith was part of the delhi capitals
success
was part of kkr if i scroll down you
have david milan who played for punjab
kings in 2021
oine morgan
who played for kkr he also captained kkr
but unfortunately he was
not picked this season chris lane from
australia also
remained unsold this season
and to tie we have been cutting aditya
there are other players as well
we have kane richardson dhawal kulkarni
cool so these were the players who were
part of the ipl season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on
ipl data analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualized the data and
answered some specific questions
formula one also known as f1 is a motor
sport defined by open wheeled single
seat race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation
here 10 teams comprising of two drivers
each compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a constructor
champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo so if you
notice the data set does not have column
names in fact none of the data sets have
column names so while importing the data
set we will assign the column names
using the names parameter
i'll show that in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id the
year in which the race was held then we
have
the round number circuit id
then the name of the
grand prix so you can see here
australian malaysian chinese spanish
monaco turkish british german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
gone pre was
held
we have the time
and a url which basically leads to the
wikipedia page of that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about
drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton rosberg
alonso
reichen
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
four name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project so here we have the
constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we
save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw and our libraries such as numpy
pandas matplotlib and c bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of f1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and the
speed of the cars has changed over the
years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon and after that i am
writing percentage matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to load the data
and assign
column names
so
i'll load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read
underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is results.csv
and then using the
names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that have been
assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma
and i'll write
header equal to
none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is racist.csv
and then
i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay
i'm going to
copy the
second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to
none
next
we'll import our third data set which is
about
drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll say
drivos.csv
then again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the
drivers data set
here
i
need to give
another parameter which is
header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import
our constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors.csv which is my
file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter
i'll go to my notepad and this time i'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to
run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
where was the issue
okay this should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned the
columns to the various datasets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above
this one
and
i'm going to merge it with
racist data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
year
after that i need
name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and recess
so here my common column
is going to be the race id because it is
present in both the data
sets and i would like to merge
so for that i'm going to use how so i'm
going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
again going to use the merge function so
i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say
df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
divorce data set
and
i'm going to select
specific columns so i'll say
driver id
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
rdf which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the
driver
all right
we'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how is going to be a left join
going to the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot
merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then
i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here i'll say
on
equal to
the common column i'll use this
constructor id
you give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
make sure
you are merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit
click enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df.drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest
lap
then we'll also drop the
status id
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore id column
and i'm going to drop the race
underscore id column
we'll also drop
driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop the
constructor underscore id column
and
i'll say access equal to
1
and in place i'll see equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say
name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
alright
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i am going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
i want to say
nationality
score
y
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i am going to replace with
just
driver
finally i see
in place
equal to
true
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i'm going to rearrange
the columns so here i'm
using the same data frame and
we have just renamed the columns so
starting with your
grand pre name round driver
nationality
and others
let's run this
up next
we're going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete
so i'll say df equal to
df
then i'll see
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the values so i'll say df equal to
df dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name
i'm going to sort it by
here
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma i'll say
ascending
equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash
n values in
the time column with
something called nan because the time
column was not registered when a driver
did not finish a race or was lab by
another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df dot
time
dot i am going to use the replace
function
and here i will say
forward slash
or backward slash
n
and i'm going to replace with
numpies nan i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
meters
next i'm going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
df.fastest.lab
dot
time
they replace
to that i have
the next column which is
speed so i'll say fastest
underscore
lap underscore
speed dot
replace
and paste it
so here
i'm going to replace
this particular value
the
backward slash
n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to
change the data types for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df dot
reset
underscore
index
i'll say
drop
equal to
true
give a comma and
say in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial processing step of the
data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll
check the head of the data set now to
see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say
print df dot shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use
df dot
info function
so it gives me the
here the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid
position order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the first slap
rank the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver the
nationality of the constructor
then here we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll see
df dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
where you go if i scroll down you can
see here we have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just
brief you about what these column names
stand for
so the year column that you see here is
the season that the grand prix took
place and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the
race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season and then
two means it was the second race of the
season so so on and so forth
then we have the name of the
driver for that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race
then we have the points column that is
the total number of points scored in the
race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down
i'll just move to the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lab
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during a race
next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release then we have the lap
speed that is the average speed of the
fastest lap
then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the
constructor nationality that is the
country where the car constructor is
based out of
okay
now
here i am going to
set my figure size to 10 comma 6 this is
going to be for all the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
df dot i'll say loc
then i'll say
df
i want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver
1 degrees
and then
i'm going to
use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
values i'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
change it to
to underscore
frame
dot
reset
underscore
index
what essentially i am doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
won a grand prix
next
i am going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in
our
analysis ideally it should be sns but sb
also will work
so i'll say sb
dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal
to driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
in the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title
let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label i'll have
driver
name
we have
the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll say
plt dot
y
text
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of
grand prix wins
only a few drivers in history
of f1 have won over 20 grand pray in
their careers and there are some drivers
who completely dominated the f1 racing
and have won over
50 grand praise in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top five or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i am doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got i'm going to
filter out only the
top 10 so i'm going to use the head
function
and
inside that i passed in 10 if i print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher who
is the position
order leader with 91 gp events then we
have hamilton vettel prost sena alonso
then we have stevert clerk and lauda
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael schumacher and has won
over
103 close to 103 races as of now
and next we have michael sumacre so this
is not the most recent
data cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y-axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis we'll have
position underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the seam drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most
gp
winners in f1
will give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then i'll have
x label which will have
number of
on pre bins
let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has won over
91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton battle
alonso clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i am finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then i'm using
the group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i am changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i am using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so you can see here i've used color as
pink and i've given a title x-label by
label and vitix
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now
our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10 if i run it
you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races
are ferrari
mclaren williams then we have mercedes
red bull tim lotus renault
and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
now let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
sb which is for c bond dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll say constructors
y-axis i'll have
constructor
on the x-axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then i'll set my
alpha to
0.8
i'll say line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge
color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
say
top 10
most
gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
wins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams more cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins
since hamilton has been on the top
for mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing
position
vary
so to do that i am going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so
i'm using this function called reg plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there is a linear
relationship between the
starting and
finishing position so on the x axis we
have the starting position on the y axis
we have the
finishing or the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right
now we can also see that
most races had up to 25 drivers you can
see the density of the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed amongst
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix
and here on the
y-axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around
2015
for almost all the circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speed
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is here
italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you
talk about the
monaco grand prix let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below
160 kilometer per hour now this is
actually expected because the monaco
grand prix
has very narrow streets and
hence the drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit all right
so
so now we are going to look at
healthcare market forecast
so as per
markets and markets.com
the healthcare analytics market is
projected to reach 75.1 billion us
dollars by 2026 from 21.1 billion us
dollars in 2021.
now talking about
india
statista.com
india's healthcare sector was about 160
billion u.s dollars in 2017
it was estimated to reach up to 372
billion us dollars by 2022.
as per rbc capital markets approximately
30 percent of the world's data is
generated by the healthcare industry
by 2025 the compound annual growth rate
of data in healthcare will reach 36
percent now that is six percent faster
than manufacturing 10 faster than
financial services and 11 percent faster
than media and entertainment
now let's see the various applications
and issues that analytics can solve in
healthcare
we will look at drug discovery
staffing and operation
and see how analytics can help predict
diseases
so talking about
drug discovery
now the drug discovery is a very long
process sometimes it takes about 12
years and costs way too much about 2.6
billion us dollars
now data analytics can increase the drug
delivery process rate in medical science
helping to gain faster approval from the
food and drug administration
it can help optimize and improve the
efficiency of clinical trials
another key development that has
happened in a number of pharmaceutical
companies like astrazeneca
bayer cleansing
and jensen research and development has
recently announced a data sharing
initiative called project data sphere
these companies have agreed to share
historical cancer research data to help
researchers in the fight against the
disease today
the database will be available online
globally and the analytics technology
would be provided by software vendor sas
now moving on
we have
staffing and operation
now this is another crucial problem that
every staff manager in hospital faces
that is the problem of staff allocations
at a given period understanding how many
people a manager should put on a staff
at any given time period can be very
challenging
if you put too many workers the risk of
having unnecessary labor costs go up
too few workers you can have poor
customer service outcomes
which can be fatal for patients
so business analysts can use data to
forecast patient admission trends at
specific times of the day and provide
insights to the staff managers to assign
the right number of staff during peak
and slow periods
next
we'll talk about
predicting diseases
so business analytics can also predict
trends in the spread of illness allowing
doctors hospitals medical staff and
individuals to adequately prepare
themselves for example in the case of
coronavirus analyzing data to predict
future spikes in cases can help
hospitals ensure the staff have enough
protective equipment and patient beds
using medical imaging algorithms
physicians can detect diabetic
retinopathy which is a condition that
damages the eye due to diabetes and
algorithms can also help detect cancer
cells in a patient
detecting cancer at an early stage has
been a focused area in healthcare for
quite some time now
the cancer moonshot initiative by former
u.s president barack obama
initiated in his second term relies on
advanced analytical techniques to pace
up the discovery of cancer cures by
identifying the trends and treatments
used worldwide that have the highest
success rate
now
let's look at the hand washing case
study in detail
so to give you some context
before the
mid 19th century
the science of bacteria was not
discovered yet
nobody knew that microorganisms could
spread diseases
back then even hospital staff did not
follow basic hygiene practices
not even doctors cared to wash their
hands
to be honest we all realized the
importance of hand washing after the
world was hit by coronavirus pandemic
now meet
dr
ignaz simelweis
he was a hungarian-born doctor and
practiced at the vienna general
hospital's maternity clinic between 1846
and 1849.
dr simul wise is regarded as the father
of infection control for discovering the
medical benefits of hand washing
dr simelweis was very disturbed by the
increasing fatality rate of mothers from
childbed fever at vienna hospital so
child bed fever is also known as
pure peril fever
it happens due to infections in the
female reproductive tract following
childbirth
this child fever was an issue of concern
throughout europe with some hospitals
having over 40 percent mortality rate so
out of every 100 mothers who used to
give birth at least 40 mothers would die
in a week or two weeks time
so the demo case study i am going to
present now concerns the work of dr
ignaz simelweis in reducing the risk of
childbid fever during child birth in
vienna hospital during the mid-19th
century so he collected and analyzed
historical data on deaths in his clinic
and established a theory
of what was contributing to increasing
deaths of mothers
now to solve a problem business analysts
would often need to collect data from
multiple sources for this demo we'll be
using three datasets that are publicly
accessible on kegel and github let me go
ahead and show you the three data sets
first
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know
more okay so this is the first data set
that i have which is called the yearly
fever motility data set so here you can
see
the first column is about year it starts
from
1784
and it goes till
1846
the next column we have is about the
total number of births that took place
at the vienna general hospital maternity
clinic and then we have the total number
of deaths reported from child bed fever
next
then we have the
fever mortality per clinic so
in the vienna hospital
there were two separate clinics that
operated between
1833 and 1846
birth one
column represents the total number of
births that took place
in clinic one
similarly that's one column represents
the total number of deaths that took
place in
clinic one of the
maternity clinic at vienna general
hospital births two and that's two
has the information about the births and
deaths that happened in clinic two
then we have our final data set
this data set is about
monthly debts which starts from
january
1841
till
march
1849
we have the total number of births and
the total number of deaths and this
monthly underscored deaths is only for
clinic one
we'll learn in detail about clinic one
and clinic two at the maternity hospital
and what they represent in detail
all right
okay
so
this is my jupyter notebook which has
the
lines of code already written i'm going
to
explain you each cell of code and we'll
explore
the hand washing case study by looking
at the outputs for each of the cells
let's start with the first cell
so here i'm going to import my first
data set which is the
yearly fever
mortality this is a csv data set
and to
load the data set i'm using the pandas
library and the read underscore csp
function
i'm using
parse underscore
dates equal to
year so this
parse underscore dates will format the
year column in the form of a date value
next
i have
set
my index to be the year column you can
see here set underscore index equal to
here and i am mentioning that in place
equal to true which means that the
original data is now modified and
updated in place
and i'm importing the data
and storing it in a variable called
yearly underscore that's
next i'm going to print my
data set
let me just
hit shift
enter we can see the result
there is an error here it says
okay this should be yearly underscore
deaths
let me run it again there you go
so here you can see we have set the year
column as our index
you can see the year column is our index
then we have the
other two columns the total number of
births and the total number of deaths
starting from
1784
till
1846
all right
now
you can see
the values for year total births and the
total number of deaths from 1784 till
1846 in the maternity clinic of vienna
hospital where similwise used to
practice
coming to the
next cell of code here
we are going to calculate the
mortality rate or the mortality
percentage for that i'm going to create
a new column called as
mortality
so here i'm mentioning my data frame
which is yearly underscore deaths that
we created above and then within square
brackets i am passing in
my new column name which is mortality
and the
formula to calculate mortality is
total
deaths
divided by
the total number of births into 100
now let's print the result
you can see here we have added a new
column called mortality and it has given
us the
mortality rate for
each of the years starting from 1784
till 1846
now next
we are
going to find out some descriptive
statistics using the describe function
so i have used yearly underscore deaths
dot describe
if i run it you can see the
count that is the total number of
rows that are there in our
data set
then we have the
mean birth so the
average birth
that has taken place in all these years
per year is around 2268.
the total debts reported in each of the
years that is the average number of
deaths is around 93 and the mortality is
around three percent or three point
three percent we have the standard
deviation
we have the
minimum value that is the
least births that took place in one of
the years was
284 and the maximum is 4010
then we have the 25th percentile the
50th percentile and the 75th percentile
we are going to create our first plot
that is
taught about
yearly mortality rate each year between
1784 till 1846
now here we are going to create a line
plot and for that
i'm going to import my matplotlib dot pi
as plt
i am setting my figure size to be 14
comma 5
and using the plot function i am going
to create my line plot
i have given my
data value as mortality rate
i'm going to use
color as green and marker as
o so o will represent as dots and after
that i am going to give a title as
mortality from childbirth fever during
childbirth i've given a x label as year
and y label as mortality rate
let's run and see the output
there you go
if i scroll down
you can see here we have a nice
line chart
now we can notice that the mortality
rate started increasing somewhere around
1823 from here you can see a spike
and gradually the
mortality rate or fatality rate from
childbirth fever started increasing from
around 1823
the reason was you can see here there
was a sharp increase after
1820
so the reason
was
around 1823
similwise clinic started giving lessons
on
pathological
anatomy so
pathology i guess you would know is the
branch of medicine that deals with the
study of
causes and effects of diseases
so doctors would take classes on the
corpses organs and tissues to learn the
reasons for the cause of the death
so after the post-mortems then they
might deliver a baby or examine a
patient possibly with pieces of
contaminated flesh remaining in their
hands
so similarwise suspected that this could
be the reason for childbed fever
we continued with his analysis and
looked for further evidence to support
his hypothesis
now till
1832 there was only one maternity clinic
at the vienna hospital
now that had become very overcrowded so
an extension was built and two clinics
were created in
1833 you can see it here
now until
1840
both clinics were used for teaching and
training medical students and midwives
so midwives are people who help mothers
deliver babies and take care of newborns
after childbirth
so after 1840
the physicians
that included doctors and medical
students used to operate in clinic one
and only midwives used to operate in
clinic 2 after 1840.
so symbolwise spotted that in clinic 1
the fatality rate for mothers from
childbed fever was 3 times more than
those who delivered in clinic 2. so you
can see here in clinic one which was the
doctor's word
and for people
who
were given trainings the mortality rate
was ten percent while in clinic two
where only the midwives operated the
mortality rate was three percent
so he again believed that in clinic one
where doctors and physicians operated
they also used to handle corpses during
autopsies before operating on pregnant
women and they never used to wash their
hands between the two jobs
but midwives in clinic 2 never went to
the autopsy room so similarwise spotted
that there were links between the lack
of hygiene of the doctors and the
mortality rate of the mothers
so let's analyze that data now
cool
so i'm going to import my second data
set which has the information about
births and deaths in clinic 1 and clinic
2. so here i'm importing my csv data set
and i'm storing it
in a data frame name called clinics
again i've used
parse underscore dates as year to format
the
date values i've given my
file location followed by the file name
and dot the extension of the file which
is csv file
again i have set my index to be the year
column
and i'm printing the head of the data
frame now let me hit shift enter
okay so here you can see
18 33 onwards
birth one death one that is for clinic
pawn then we have both two that's two
for clinic two
next
we are going to calculate the mortality
for both the clinics that is clinic one
and clinic two
so what i am doing here is i am creating
two columns mortality one and mortality
two so mortality one is for clinic one
then mortality two is for clinic two
again the formula is the same deaths
divided by births into hundred is the
mortality rate
let me run it
and now we are going to see the first 10
rows from our newly created data frame
you can see here we have added
two more columns mortality one and
mortality two
and these are the results
now if you notice
see the mortality rate
for the clinic one where
dr simelweis used to practice
or the physicians who also operated on
the
dead bodies
used to practice so the mortality rate
is high there
now let's
compare
and visualize the mortality rate
at both the clinics so here i am again
setting my figure size to be 14 comma 5
i've used
clinics dot index mortality 1 i've given
a label as clinic 1
color i'm using a steel marker is
o so this o will make sure for each of
the years we have a
dot or
a round shape
similarly for clinic 2 we have mortality
2 i'm using
blue color again marker as o
then i am giving a legend
a title called mortality from child bed
fever during childbirth i also have a
while label called mortality rate
let's run it
now if i scroll down you can see
the mortality rate
from
1833 onwards till 1846 for both the
clinics
the teal color represents clinic 1 and
the blue color represents clinic 2.
so from this graph we can see that the
death rate at clinic 1 was significantly
higher after
1840 you can see there has
a huge spike
compared to clinic 2 where only the
midwives practiced and they never
operated on the dead bodies in the
autopsy room
so now doctor simul vice had strong
evidence to believe that the doctors
were transmitting infectious flesh or
you can say material substances from
previous operations to mothers through
their hands and this was leading to
childbirth fever
so far
we have seen in our analysis till
1846
when dr simelweis in mid
1847 asked his colleagues and fellow
physicians at maternity clinic one to
wash their hands with chlorinated lyme
solution before attending pregnant
mothers and the results were significant
so let's see the final analysis of
clinic one where doctor simula wise
practiced and how he was able to reduce
the mortality rate
now i am going to load the
monthly
deaths data set that has information
from january 1841 till march 1849
and after 1849 his contract was
terminated and he was asked to leave the
vienna hospital i'll tell you why he was
asked to leave
a little later
let's load the final data set
now okay so
i'm going to import my final data set
which is the monthly underscore deaths
dot csv i'm storing it
in a variable called monthly underscore
data let me run it
so here you can see
the
data for
all the months starting from
january 1841 till march 1849
next
i'm going to find the monthly
mortality at clinic one
so
i'm going to divide the deaths divided
by births into 100
so here you can see we have created new
column called proportional underscore
deaths
that has the
death rate for each of the months
now the doctors in clinic one started
washing their hands in june
1847 before carrying out delivery
operations
so
we have divided
the original data into two data frames
called
before washing and
then we have after washing we will set
the start of hand washing date to
1st of june
18
47 you can see here i have said
start of hand washing pandas dot 2 data
frame i am giving my
hand washing start date that is first of
june 1847
or washing data frame will have all the
values that lie prior to june
1847 so here i have subset my data i'm
saying
date should be less than
a date which is first of june
1847 and after washing should be
greater than equal to first of june
1847.
run this
i'll print my before
washing data frame you can see
it has taken all the values till
may 1847
and for after washing we have all the
values starting from june 1847 till
we have
march 1849
so we have split
months data into before and after hand
washing start date
now let's
plot our final
graph that shows the difference in the
mortality rate of mothers
before and after hand washing
so here
i'm setting ax which is the axis
before washing
dot plot will create
a line plot i'm saying x to be date y to
be proportional depths i'm giving my
label to be beforehand washing i'm using
color
as c which is for cn
then here b represents blue
this is for after hand washing again x
should be date y should be proportional
underscore deaths here i'm using a line
style to be dotted lines to just
you know compare the
plots
i've set my while label to be proportion
that's let's run it
and you can see the
result
let me scroll down
there you go on the x-axis we have the
date the y-axis we have the proportion
depth
the
cyan color represents beforehand washing
that is the solid line and we have the
dotted lines for
after hand washing
now you can see how
starting from the summer of
1847 the proportion of deaths got
reduced significantly less than five
percent you can see here
so this was when symbol wise made hand
washing
mandatory
now
we'll calculate the difference in
average monthly percentage debts before
and after hand washing so what i'm doing
is i'm creating
two variables before proportion and
after proportion
then we are going to subtract
before proportion mean minus the after
proportion mean if you see the
difference you can see here
it is eight point three percent so from
ten percent we just
reduced it to less than three percent
so this was all about the
hand washing case study that simulvise
had conducted using different data sets
so we performed this exploratory data
analysis using three data sets
and you explored how using pandas and
matplotlib you can create
different charts and analyze data
yearly data
or time series data
the sad part is that with all this
exploratory analysis and the findings dr
simelweis made his superiors at vena
hospital refused to
accept his theory and he was met with a
lot of criticism
medical community rejected his discovery
in march 1849 and he was forced to leave
the vienna general hospital
one reason we can argue as business
analysts is that statistical analysis
and data visualization were very
uncommon those days in the field of
medical science
similarwise only published his data as
long tables of raw data but he couldn't
show any graphs or confidence intervals
to support his hypothesis
his ideas were considered as offense to
the medical community he hurt them
since similar wise meant that doctors
were the cause of increased deaths
he believed in another theory called
meismus which basically means some bad
component in the air was the cause of
childbed fever deaths
after two decades
when
joseph lister and luis pasture produced
more evidence of the germ theory and
antiseptic techniques only then the
value of hand washing was appreciated
but nevertheless his work was based on
evidence supported by numbers showing
that simple hand washing by healthcare
workers could save millions of lives
later he did get some recognition
the budapest university where doctor
ignace samuel wise used to teach
after getting terminated from vienna
general hospital is now named as
similavis university
in january 2019
statue of dr
semelweis was unveiled at the world
health organization by the current
director general mr trados you can see
on the right on the left we have the
state secretary of the ministry of
foreign affairs and trade
from hungary
on the 100th anniversary of his death
the government of austria issued a
postage stamp in his honor
and in march 2020 after the world was
hit by coronavirus google also
recognized symbol wise
hand-washing findings and gave him a
will doodle
that brings us to the end of our
interesting video tutorial on dr
simulva's hand washing case study using
python i hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you